AFTERNOON MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
AND THE PUBLIC WELCOME TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT A COUPLE
OF MINUTES TO GO THROUGH  FEW
OPTIONS AND PROTOCOLS FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY WITH A COUPLE OF
OPEN THREE LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WERE TO REQUIRING
THAT NASTY WARNING ALL COMMON
AREAS AND SHARED SPACES IN THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING THIS HEARING
ROOM. WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS TO CONTINUE
PRACTICING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM IN
ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN THE STATE
CAPITAL. WE'RE MEETING IF
ANYONE IS ROOM LOSS TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. UNLESS TO COME THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. BUT YOU NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AFTER DEATH
SPEAKING CONNECTS THE ROOMS ARE
RETURNING YOUR SEATS. IF YOU
LEAVE THIS ROOM PLEASE OMIT
ELEVATOR USED TO NO MORE THAN
FOUR PEOPLE AT ONE TIME. FOR
ILLNESS IS CALLING ME IN VIA
PHONE. WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THAT MRS CAN USE TO TESTIFY. ON
A BILL. THE BEST THING ABOUT
ONE GLASS OF THE FOG UP IF YOU
HAVE YOUR- MATHIS RIGHT. THE
CALL NUMBER FOR THE HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THE
FINEST PHONE NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE NINE YOUR
TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SELL AS
YOU OFFER THE BILL BEGINS
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE A BILL. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE LUMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE SUCH AS MUTING
YOUR TV. LIVESTREAM BROADCAST
AND OTHER SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE INTERRUPTION AND SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
BILL YOUR MAN I LIVE LINE. YOU
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF INTO YOUR
CALL TO SPEAK. FOR EVERYONE IS
ALSO WHERE THIS COMMITTEE
ACCEPTS WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL. ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ENCOURAGES THOSE WHO HAVE HAD
ANY TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES TO
USE THIS OPTION. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE CONTINUE
USING METHODS TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF HEALTH CONCERNS.
REALLY ME TESTIMONY FOR PARTNER
WITNESSES. IDENTIFIED BY EACH
AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO TWO PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT. AND TWO PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. IT IS INDIVIDUALS
WHAT THREE MINUTES MAXIMUM TO
SPEAK. IF THEY'RE LESSEN TO
PARTNER WITNESSES REGARDING.
REGARDLESS OF SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THE MAXIMUM THREE
MINUTES STILL APPLIES. AFTER
PARTY WHAT IS THEIR DONE.
EVERYONE ELSE WE PERMITTED TO
SAY THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION IF
ANY IMPOSITION ON THE BILL. OF
NOT A PRIMARY WITNESS YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION OF
THE BILL. I'LL BE ASKING THE
PHONE OPERATOR TO MOVE ON THE
NEXT BEAKER WHEN YOUR TIME IS
UP. THE ASSEMBLY IS EXPERIENCE
A NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS
IN THE PAST LAST FEW YEARS. SO
EVERYONE IS CLEAR. CONDUCT THE
DISTRAUGHT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK AND
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON IF
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN PERSON OR
VIA REMOTE VIDEO STATION. OR
ENTER ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
TALKING YOU'RE MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. EVEN LONGER
THAN TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THIS BILL BEING
DISCUSSED BY THE COMMITTEE THAT
TIME OR OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS.
TO ADDRESS ANY DESTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IS THE
MINISTER FOR HEARING PROCESS I
WOULD RECKON THE STOP AND
WARNED THAT CONTINUED
DISRUPTIONS THEY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING. I ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT. I MADE
SEVERAL RECESSED HEARING. JUST
CONDUCT STILL DOES NOT STOP I
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE THE
SERGEANTS IN REMOVING THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THE HEARING
INCLUDING ESCORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. THEY ARE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT. THANK YOU ADVANCE YOUR
CORPORATION. THIS HEARING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES THAT
SENT ASSEMBLY RODRIGUEZ WILL BE
SUBSTITUTING WE HAVE NOT ALLIES
ON THE AGENDA INCLUDING WHAT I
CONSENT THE BILL CONSENT IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB SIX
THIRTY FOUR BUT SENATE LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE. BEFORE WE
BEGIN NEWS DOUBLE SAPPORO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR THE QUORUM. COOPER THE
COOPER PRESIDENT VOEPEL. COOLEY
THEY'RE COOLEY PRESIDENT
O'DONNELL HERE BUT ALL PRESENT
RODRIGUEZ SO YOUR TOTAL HERE.
CALDERON AS CHAIR QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE OTHER MEMBERS
THE STARTING THINK CALENDAR THE
TEAM MEMBER WAS TO MOVE THIS
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WITH IT CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE MOTION. THANK YOU
SECOND. THE FIRST ONE IS WITH
THE AUTO AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY. A
ROLL CALL PLEASE COOPER I'M
SORRY ON SENATE BILL SIX THREE
FOUR BYE COMMITTEE ON LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH RECKONS
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR COOPER HI. COOPER HI
VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON I
COOLEY ALL RIGHT COOLEY I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL HIRED
RODRIGUEZ. SARTO HI SORRY ARE
TOO HIGH. THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES REPLACE ON CALL THE BILL
HAS FIVE ALL TO BE PLACED ON
CALL WE'RE NOT MOVING ON THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA
STARTING WITH SB SEVENTY SIXTH
INTERNAL SEN. YOU MAY PRESENT
WHEN READY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS AND I'LL PUT IT THIS
WAY I'M BACK. I'VE BEEN
PERSISTENT WITH THIS BILL HUMAN
RELATIONS AND FINANCE OF NOT
LIKE THAT. THEY THINK IT GIVES
UP SOME OF THEIR AUTHORITY AND
THE BARGAINING PROCESS I GUESS.
BUT THESE EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
ARE KIND OF THE FORGOTTEN
INDIVIDUALS. THEY THROUGH THEIR
CAREERS AGREED TO ADVANCE IN
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY. BUT IT
OFTEN DOESN'T NECESSARILY HELP
THEM. THEY GET THE HEADACHES OF
THAT HIGHER RESPONSIBILITY. BUT
SOME OF THE BENEFITS THAT THE-
REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES RECEIVED
THEY DO NOT. THIS BILL TRIES TO
HELP THEM. UNDER CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES IF THEY HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT. THEIR ONLY
RECOURSE. IS THE COURTS. THEY
CAN GO TO THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD. BUT THESE ARE OFTEN
ROUTINELY REJECTED. SO THIS
CLASS OF EMPLOYEES IS GREATLY I
WOULD ARGUE DISADVANTAGED. AND
THEN AT THEIR THE KEY EMPLOYEES
THE MANAGERS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM.
TO MAKE OUR GOVERNMENT WORK.
THERE DISADVANTAGED SO WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. IF DREAMLAND A
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. WE ALLOW THE
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES. AFTER
THEY'VE EXHAUSTED THE NORMAL
GRIEVANCE PROCESS. THEY CAN
REQUEST ARBITRATION. I'M NOT
HISTORICALLY BEEN A FAN OF
ARBITRATION BUT IN THIS CASE I
SEE ITS APPLICATION. THE
CLASSROOM POLICIES THAT ARE
MOST DESERVING. OF THAT BENEFIT
NOW. THE AND AS THE INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN A SPIRE THE GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY MANAGEMENT. THEY
CAN HAVE SOME HOPE THAT THEY
WON'T BE SO LONELY. AS I SAY I
THINK THE INTEREST OF THE-
APARTMENTS FINANCE IN HR WITH
THE PASSED THROUGH JUST TO
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN. LEVERAGE IN
THE PROCESS. BUT THEY'RE NOT
THAT MANY OF THE EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES. AND I DO NOT THINK
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN ONEROUS
BURDEN. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL THAT WE'VE ADDED A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET. PHIL THERE
CAN BE A RE EXAMINATION IF WE
DON'T THINK THIS IS WORKING
WELL. IN FIVE YEARS HALF. BUT
IT WILL SPARE US I WOULD ARGUE
NEEDLESS LITIGATION. AND I
THINK THE DISADVANTAGE THAT
PLEASE EXPLODED EMPLOYEES FEEL.
I'D ASK IF YOU'D BE SO KIND AS
TO LET THIS BILL MOVE ON AS WE
HAVE BEFORE. AND FINALLY GAVE
SOME HOPE TO OR EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES. WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES JOHN LEVEL REPRESENTS
THE CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SHAYLA SILVA DIFFERENTIATION
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPERVISORS THAT WOULD BE OUR
WITNESSES MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WHAT'S THE
FIRST UP OUR PURPOSE IS TO
SUPPORT OUR JUNGLE LEVEL.
OPERATOR. YOU'RE LIKE COULD BE
OPTIMISED LEVEL DISCORDANT
UNMUTE YOURSELF OKAY THANK YOU
CAN YOU CAN THE COMMITTEE HERE
ME YES WITH HANDS ON. OKAY
THANK YOU- JOHN LEVEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION. WE
WANT TO COMMAND- CENTER NIELSEN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN THIS
AREA. THIS BILL WILL- CREATE.
AN ATMOSPHERE WHERE PROBLEMS
AND GRIEVANCES CAN BE SOLVED
QUICKLY AND WE'RE GONNA A
MINIMAL COST. RIGHT NOW IS
SENATOR NIELSEN POINTS OUT.
ALEX ARE JUST ROUTINELY REJECTS
GRIEVANCES WHY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T BUT THEN THE OPTION IS TO
GO TO LITIGATION. AND
LITIGATION IS VERY EXPENSIVE.
IN OUR ORGANIZATION THE AVERAGE
LITIGATION COST IS ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND WE WOULD SUBMIT
BUT BUT BUT BUT- STATE BEARS
THAT SIMILAR COST HAND WITH
LITIGATION SOMETIMES CASES GET.
STRUNG OUT WHERE THE DAMAGES
INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY BY THE
RECENT WALKER IN CASE WHERE THE
STATE IS LOOKING AT POTENTIAL
DAMAGES OF OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- THERE'S SOME.
WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY DIFFERENT
EFFECT CASE HAD GONE TO
ARBITRATION THE OTHER THING
THIS BILL DOES IN THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. IS IT
COURAGE'S THE PARTIES TO TRY
AND SOLVE- DISPUTES WHY BECAUSE
OF THE BILL PROVIDES THAT THE
LOSER MUST PAY FOR THE COSTS OF
ARBITRATION. SO HERE FOR A CCSO
FILES A REQUEST FOR
ARBITRATION. AND CAL H. R.
LOOKS AT IT- AND THEY HAVE TO-
DETERMINE OKAY ARE WE GOING TO
WIN THIS ONE OR NOT. ANALYSTS
ARE A 100% SURE WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN IS THEY'RE GOING TO SIT
DOWN AND TRY AND WORK OUT A
SETTLEMENT. CCSO IS IN THE SAME
BOAT SO THE GENIUS OF THIS
BILL. IS THAT IT PROVIDES FOR
ARBITRATION. WHICH IS LESS
EXPENSE OF THE MEDICATION AND
QUICKER BUT ALL IN. THE PARTY.
TO TRY AND INTERPRET OF THE-
WORKOUT- SETTLEMENT CAN WE PUT
THIS. INPUT RECENT- SENATOR-
INTO. WE RESPECTFULLY- WOULD
COMMAND THIS BILL TO THE
COMMITTEE OF FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT PARTNER WITNESSES
SHAYLA SILVA. OPERATOR. SHANE
IF YOU CANNOT HEAR US JUST GO
AHEAD AND ON YOUR PHONE. THE
WITNESSES LINES ARE OPEN. WE
SEE IF I CAN SEE HER NAME ON
HERE YOU SAID HER LAST NAME WAS
SILVA. YES. WE DO NOT HAVE A
SEAMUS SILVA ON. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT MOVES WITH THIS IS IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND ONE OF WHOM
WAS TO TESTIFY IN THIS MATTER.
SEEING NONE WE'LL GO BACK TO
THE OPERATOR. WHEN THIS IS ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. THE SHOW
SUPPORT AND ARE ON THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE ZERO IN EIGHTEEN T. AFRICAN
GO AHEAD GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE THE PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. SO AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND THE QUEUE IN
A IS OPEN SO GO AHEAD AT ONE
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. WE JUST
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP FOR ANYBODY
ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SHOW SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. SHE
WITH THE ST ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU I WE ARE NOT.
SB SEVENTY SIX- YES. OKAY A
PRODUCT BUT- I'LL GIVE YOU
ANOTHER REMINDER FOR SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO LINE. SIXTY FIVE. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME IT IS A LITTLE
THAT. HEARING YES PLEASE
PROCEED. MY APOLOGIES I WAS
EXPECTING YOU TO CALL IN FOR ME
TOO BUT THIS IS SHEILA OF ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CAL STATE SUPERVISORS AND WE
ECHO THE REMARKS OF MR LEVEL
AND ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYMORE WHAT IS THE NETWORK GO
TO LINE. I AM SO SCARED SORRY
WHAT WAS THAT NOT PROCEED
PLEASE. OKAY WHAT LITTLE LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
SIXTY SEVEN. OUR MEDICARE
MEMBERS TAMARAN REPAIR AND
RENEW SO CITRIX THING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL FLIGHT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW THE
OUT OF THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE. OKAY AND DO SO
OPPOSITION FOR SB SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SO WE HAVE NO PROMISES
OPPOSITION EARLIER THIS IS THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL OPPOSITION OF
THE PHONE OPERATOR. THERE'S
NOBODY QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME
ALL GIVE ONE MORE REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SEVENTY SIX.
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR COOLEY. SENATOR
THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I DO THINK IN A WORK
FORCE EVERYONE IN THE WORK
FORCE WANTS TO HAVE HOPE AFTER
INVESTING THEMSELVES IN THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THEY HAVE A
DISCRIMINATORY SPEECH THAT
THERE IS SOME. PROSPECT FOR A
FAIR RESOLUTION OR IS A
FEARLESS OR TO HAVE A SHOT AT A
FAIR AND BALANCED
CONSIDERATION. AN OUTCOME. AND
WHILE I DO THINK THE ESTABLISH.
OTHER GRIEVANCE LEVELS WHICH
THIS BILL CONTINUES RESPECT.
OUR IS NOT ILL SERVED BY A
FOREIGN ARBITRATION AS A FINAL
STOP. IN AS A LAWYER I ACTUALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THE EXPENSE OF
LITIGATION. BOB TO ENCUMBER THE
COURTS TO OF PART OF THE COURT
CALENDAR. AND OF TO DEFERRED
THE ABILITY GET RESOLUTION AN
APPOINTMENT MATTER. ARE ALL
NEGATIVE VALUES THAT THIS BILL
PROVIDES ALTERNATIVE TO SEOUL I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. GIVEN A
MOTION FOR THEIR SECOND. THANK
SENATOR RICKLES IN THE BILL.
THE FAMILY MEMBERS JUST KEEP IN
MIND AGAIN THAT THERE HAD A LOT
OF THESE GOOD LOYAL EMPLOYEES
OUT THERE LABORING IN THE
TRENCHES ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT. AND
WOULD LIKE TO LET THEM FEEL
THAT THEY ARE REPRESENTED AT
LEAST THAT THE TERROR IN
KNOWLEDGE WITH AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THEIR CASE. FOR A
LITTLE BIT BETTER WORKING
CIRCUMSTANCES I WOULD ASK AGAIN
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS
FOR FURTHER- JUST YEAR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. ON THE SENATE BILL
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR.
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COOPER HI COOPER HI
VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON I
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL
AYE O'DONNELL AYE RODRIGUEZ
SCIARRETTO HI SO WE ARE TO LIVE
FIVE ZERO ON CALL THE BILL
PASSES BUT ISRAEL PHONE CALL
THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS. WE GOT A NUMBER THREE
WELL ACTUALLY I SEE SAID
RUSSELL THERE. MR GARCIA. WELL
THERE IS I DON'T SEE COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MY FAULT. HELLO I
REMEMBER THREE SB TWO OH SIX
SENATE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TENNESSEE. MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE A PRESENT
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EVALUATION THIS BILL INTO
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND LONG STORY SHORT SB TWO
OH SIX. VICE EQUAL TREATMENT
FOR EQUAL WORK. COULD IN THE
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED IN THE
FIRE FIRE BILL OF RIGHTS THAT
FULL TIME FIREFIGHTERS ALSO
HAPPY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU. WHAT AND WHAT IS THE
SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE NONE THE
NOT ANOTHER OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WHAT WE DO. MISTER
STEWART. THERE IT'S ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SORRY NESTLE THE PHONE LINE
WHEN THIS IS SUPPORT OPERATOR.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME TWO SIX TWO
WILL FINALLY FIGHT RADIO- I'M
SO SORRY TWO OH SIX YES. PLEASE
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR- TWO OH
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE ONE WE HAVE A
COUPLE QUEUED UP. WITH
OPERATORS. OUR FIRST ONE. WILL
BE FROM LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIXTY. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS EDUARDO MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. PINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN READ RESEARCH IT'S
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE THANK YOU THE
AUTHOR IN THIS COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB. TWO ZERO SIX.
STRUCTURE NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU REMOVED WITNESSES
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE OLDER PHONE LINE.
THIS IS AN AWFUL LOT IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. SB TWO
ZERO SIX FOUR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO GET
TO EXPRESS OUR POSITION FOR TWO
ZERO SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO NOBODY IS
GIVING UP MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. I'LL BE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE. THIS
IS THE AUTO. QUESTION HELLO.
GIVE UP THRUGH AUGUST FIRST BY
MISTER SARDO SECOND BY MISTER
O'DONNELL- CENTER OLYMPIC RINGS
BEFORE WE'VE A LOT OF PERMANENT
PART TIME INDIVIDUALS IN THE
FIRE SERVICE AND ALSO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THOSE FOLKS
REWARDED SOME OF THE- THE-
PROTECTIONS YOU BRING UP IN
YOUR BILL SELIGER BRING THIS
FORWARD- THE RECOMMENDATION IS-
I. DO PASSED ME FOR JUDICIARY.
SECRETARY WOULD CONTROL CALL
PLEASE. ON SENATE BILL TWO OH
SIX BY CENTER MCGUIRE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COOPER HI COOPER HI
VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON HI
COOLEY ALL RIGHT COOLEY AYE
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I
RODRIGUEZ SAY RTO HI C. R.
TÁI FIVE ZERO ONE CALL CENTER
YOUR BILLS FIVE ZERO ONES ON
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE- WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
LISTENER DORADO. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- YES
I'M HERE TO PRESENT S. B. TWO
SEVENTY- THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVE ACCURATE AND TIMELY
BARGAINING UNIT INFORMATION
WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY ENTITLED
TO BY LAW SO THAT THEY MAY
FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
BARGAINING UNIT AS A WHOLE
THERE'S PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM POLL- IMPLORED TO CURE
THE PROBLEM RESPOND AND AVOID.
ANYTHING FURTHER THERE ARE NO
NEW REQUIREMENTS OFFER THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS- JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- ESPECIALLY
DURING EMERGENCIES HAVING
ACCURATE AND TIMELY INFORMATION
IS ESSENTIAL. THE EMPLOYEES
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REPRESENTATIVE HAS THE MORAL
AND LEGAL DUTY TO WATCH OUT FOR
THE WELFARE OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES THEY REPRESENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR THAT
WE'VE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. EDUARDO MARTINEZ AND
LUIS SANCHEZ YES AB WITH ON THE
PHONE LINE OPERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB TWO SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. UP VOTE.
MESSAGE DID YOU WANT THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO GO FIRST
YES. OKAY I DON'T HAVE IT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- EDUARDO MARTINEZ
ABOUT HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ATHLETES
SPEAKERS PROP COSPONSORED SB
TWO SEVENTY. PUT SIMPLY THE
FELT ABOUT PRESERVING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE LAW PASSED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. INTENDED TO PROTECT
WORKERS- THAT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED MANY PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
HAVE FAILED TO SUBMIT TIMELY
AND ACCURATE NEW HIRE WITH- THE
PANDEMIC AND STRENGTHEN THE
NEED FOR THIS BILL WE NEED THE
INFORMATION TO QUICKLY
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR MEMBERS
AND ENSURE THEY HAVE ISSUE PP
ACT ABOUT RESPECTING BACK DEAN
FOR QUICK ACTION. AND THEY ARE
QUITE- FIFTY TO SEVENTY NINE TO
INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE NOT TO
PENALIZE EMPLOYERS PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WOULD BE ONLY BE
SUBJECT TO A PENALTY IF PER
TERM AND PREPARE AND VIOLATION-OF THE LAW AND ANY OTHER KEEP.
COLLECTED GO BACK TO THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND. BOB BILL
COULD STAND FROM TO A BILL
BECAUSE MANY OF. BY YEAR. I WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
PRIMARY SUPPORT IS LIBBY
SANCHEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LED THE
PHANTASM TOGETHER THAT THE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE IT IS
OUR SINCEREST HOPE THAT THE
RESULT OF THE S. B. TWO SEVENTY
WILL BE THAT UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGES ARISING OUT OF
FIVE VIOLATIONS OF GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT. NO LONGER HAVE TO BE
FILED AND THAT THE ATTORNEYS
FEES AND COSTS PROVISIONS OF
THE MEASURE WILL NEVER HAVE TO
BE RELIED UPON. THE BILL IS
UNFORTUNATELY NECESSARY HOWEVER
BECAUSE IN THE SHORT TIME THAT
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT HAS BEEN ON
THE BOOKS SOME EMPLOYERS HAVE
SIMPLY BEEN UNWILLING TO COMPLY
WITH A STRAIGHT FORWARD AND NOT
UNDULY BURDENSOME OBLIGATIONS
CONTAINED THEREIN. IT'S BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT THE LACK
OF COMPLIANCE IS DUE ONLY TO
THE EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO SCORE
COMPLIANCE WITH IMPUNITY IN
OTHER WORDS NO ONE'S AFRAID OF
THE REPERCUSSIONS OF VIOLATION
BECAUSE THERE REALLY ARE NOT.
EXCEPT OF COURSE THE PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
UNIONS WHO ARE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED IN NUMEROUS WAYS BY
THE ISRAELIS AND- THE INTENT OF
LABOR PROTECTIONS AT THE LEVEL
AND ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT. IN THE
EQUALISING MANNER THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED THE BILL A
FABLESS IS A THOUGHTFUL AND
TRULY BALANCED APPROACH TO
REMEDYING THE PROBLEM. FIRST
THE BILL CONTAINS CONTINUES TO
BE IN THE EMPLOYERS COURT WHERE
THE EMPLOYER CAN COMPLY WITH
THE LAW AND NOTHING HAPPENS NO
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE NO
POTENTIAL FOR ATTORNEY FEES AND
COSTS. BACK IN THE BILL
ENCOURAGES RESOLUTION BY
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CARE AND ESTABLISHING A NEUTRAL
ATTORNEY FEE STRUCTURE AGAIN
THE BILL WORK HOPEFULLY
OPTIMISTIC WILL RARELY IF EVER
HAVE TO BE YEARS BUT WITHOUT IT
THE PRODUCTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE THOUGHT THEY WERE
IMPARTING TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKERS. UNDER GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ALL BUT
ILLUSORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NESTLED WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM. I SEE A
COUPLE. THEIR CELL COMING UP TO
LIKE. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORDER. AND GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID
CHIU CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL IN SUPPORT AND
THANKFUL TO SUNDRESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KRISTEN BROWN WITH CFTA UNION
OF EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFY
PROFESSIONALS HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN PRODUCTION WAS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
REMOVED WITNESSES OPPOSITION WE
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS JASON
SMELSER OPERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM HERE- THE
BIGOTRY CARE NUMBERS- MY NAME
IS JACOB SMELTER AND I'M HERE
TODAY TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
PRISM PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS IN MANAGEMENT FIRST I
JUST WANT TO SAY VERY CLEARLY
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AUTHORED THE SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS ARE FRUSTRATED BY
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS YOU'RE SIMPLY
FAILING TO DO THE JOB THAT'S
REQUIRED OF THEM UNDER THE LAW.
THAT THERE ARE THOSE EMPLOYERS-
WE CAN SEE WHY THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT TO APPLY A
REASONABLE MONETARY PENALTY IN
THAT SCENARIO TO DRIVE-
PERFORMANCE- WE HAVE NO DEBATE.
AT ALL ON THAT FRONT. WE WOULD
ARGUE THOUGH- IS THAT THE BILL
GOES TOO FAR BY APPLYING THESE
PENALTIES FOR INACCURATE OR
INCOMPLETE DATA THAT'S PROVIDED
TO A PUBLIC EMPLOYER PROVIDED
BY A PUBLIC EMPLOYER WHO'S
ATTEMPTING TO COMPLY IN GOOD
FAITH. SO THE PROBLEM WITH THE
BILL- IS THAT A DATA INTEGRITY
TO EXIST ACROSS EVERY TYPE OF
GOVERNMENT PRIVATE BODY. DATA
INTEGRITY CHALLENGES DATA
ERRORS ARE DIVING INTO A
FUTURE. OF DATA SETS NOT A BUG-
THIS ISN'T NEWS TO ANYBODY
WHO'S MANAGE DATA- THE PROBLEM
WITH SB TWO SEVENTY IN
PARTICULAR THAT IT ONLY ALLOWS
THREE- CORRECTIONS AND A YEAR
RIGHT TO CURE THREE TIMES IN A
YEAR OR SO. WHY IS THIS A
PROBLEM THREE TIMES SHOULD BE
ENOUGH RIGHT WELL IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT COUNTY I'LL JUST TAKE
MY COUNTY THAT I LIVE IT. OTHER
TWENTY SIX BARGAINING UNITS- IF
YOU TAKE ALL OF THE REPORTS
THAT ARE UNDER THE LAW THAT'S
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY
FILINGS IN A YEAR. OF WHICH
THERE COULD BE A SINGLE DATA
ERROR IN EACH ONE THERE WILL BE
I GUARANTEE YOU THERE WILL BE A
DATA ERROR IN EACH ONE. SO
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE YEAH
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN-
WOULD BE TECH TECHNICALLY UNDER
THE BILL SUBJECT TO PENALTIES-
GIVE YOU TAKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TWENTY ONE
BARGAINING UNITS THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN TOTAL FILINGS.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FOURTEEN STATEWIDE BARGAINING
UNIT SEVENTEEN CAMPUS SPECIFIC
BARGAINING UNITS FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY. ANNUAL FILINGS THEY CAN
CORRECT DATA ERRORS WHICH
SHOULD BE EXPECTED ONLY THREE
TIMES AROSE DURING THE PENALTY.
WE JUST CAN'T SUPPORT THAT-%
UNDER THE CURRENT. STRUCTURE OF
THE BILL BUT AGAIN WE WOULD NOT
OPPOSE THE BILL THAT SIMPLY
IMPOSE PENALTIES ON EMPLOYERS.
WHO FAIL TO COMPLY A FULL STOP-
SO WITH THAT- THAT IS SHARED
MEMBERS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR NO VOTE. TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MESSAOUD.
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION. SAYING NO WHEN.
WILL WITNESSES PHONE. AND
OPPOSITION. RESEARCH YOUR NAME
ORGANISE OPPOSED. OPERATOR- I
SHOW OPPOSITION. YES YES MISTER
CHAIR TO SHOW OPPOSITION TO- S.
B. TWO SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO OPERATE WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER ARE PLAIN
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
SEVEN YEAR OPEN PLEASE- YOU-
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I WAS IN
SUPPORT I DID NOT HEAR THE CALL
FOR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO SEVEN WE
TALKED THAT WITH SMART TV
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL AIR. RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR BRAMBELL
CALLING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION APOLOGIES
FOR BEING OUT OF ORDER WE ARE
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
KRISTOFF MEYER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES- I TOO AM
IN SUPPORT- SB TWO SEVENTY-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IT ALREADY
FOR TAKING SUPPORT AS WELL
THAT'S FINE HERE. OKAY PLEASE
GO AHEAD OF WITH SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ONE
SEVENTY FOUR GO AHEAD. YOU JUST
WENT BLANK FIFTY SIX EUROPEN.
LINE FIFTY SIX CAN YOU HEAR IT
YES I'M SPEAKING CAN YOU HEAR
ME. WE CAN'T OKAY- I AM CALLING
IN OPPOSITION THE DISTILLING
GIBBONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AT LIKE THE LINE MY COMMENTS
THAT OF THAT MR SPONSOR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I LINE SEVENTY
YOUR OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ELIZABETH AT THE BELL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN TO GO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. I'LL GIVE ANOTHER
REMINDER- JUST EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME YOU'RE TAKING BOTH
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE TO CATCH
ON BEHALF OF THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE THE CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. NEXT IS ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEGAN MERRY ARE WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THE NINE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAPP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE EXPIRED
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU. I'LL BE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE JUST
GOT ANOTHER ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE THAT WE WILL TO IT WILL
TAKE ONE LAST ONE YES. OKAY TO
MARKET UP BUT WHAT WE WILL GO
TO ONE FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE- HATE
IT THIS WILL BE THE LAST AN
OPERATOR. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MATT KREMIN TERRA
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE THE LAST ONE
YES. OKAY ONE FIFTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STATE FOR JUST
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED BY
MISTER SMITH. THAT IS IT. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. BUT JUST WITH THE
SENATOR I'M ALLOWED TO TALK
ABOUT THE DATA ERRORS- WELL SIR
YOU'RE ALLOWED THREE DATA
ERRORS. I THINK IT'S THREE-
ERRORS BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THERE'S A TEN DAY CURE
PERIOD NO MATTER HOW MANY TIMES
SO THIS IS NOT YOU GET THREE
CHANCES AND AFTER THAT NO
MATTER WHAT YOU YOU YOU HAVE- A
TEN DAY CURE PERIOD- AND YOU
KNOW THE POINT OF THIS IS LOOK
THIS IS. IF IT WERE TO BE SO
SERIOUS AS TO IMPOSE THE
MAXIMUM PENALTY THAT'S MONEY
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYER THAT'S NOT WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION'S THE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE LOOKING FOR
THEY'RE LOOKING TO FIX THE
PROBLEM GET THEIR ATTENTION TO
FIX THE PROBLEM SO. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING WHERE THEY'RE GONNA
BE WAITING AND WISHING AND
HOPING THAT THERE IS ERROR SO
THAT THEY CAN- GOTCHA GOTCHA
AGAIN- SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THE MAXIMUM PENALTY
IS TEN THOUSAND THE PURPOSE
GOING TO LOOK THROUGH T ALL.
WHAT'S THE BUDGET OF THE
EMPLOYER THE SEVERITY ANY PRIOR
HISTORY SO I THINK WE'RE JUST
MAKING THE MAKING THE
OPPOSITION'S MAKING TOO MUCH OF
A BIG DEAL THEY REALLY OUGHT TO
BE FIGURING OUT HOW TO GIVE.
ACCURATE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
JUST TO GIVE A REPORT. OUT OF
SOMETHING LIKE SEVEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYERS TO IN FORTY TWO
DIDN'T EVEN SUBMIT ANYTHING.
FORGET THE A MISTAKE THEN
SUBMIT ANYTHING. SO I AND SOME
OF THEM HAVE NEVER DONE IT
SINCE THE LAW WAS PASSED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THE THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD SAY TO THAT THANK
YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT. AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. I CARE.
WEBER WOOD MISTER L. OKAY. I'M
THRILLED ON THAT SB RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY SO WE IS
THERE A MOTION. FOR FIRST CALL
MISTER CALDERON SEQUESTERED
DONAL SECRETARY CULTURAL PLEASE
AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS. ON SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN
ZERO BY SENATOR DROUGHT SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COOPER HI COOPER HI
VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON I'D
COOLEY COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL AYE
DONAL AYE RODRIGUEZ SCIARRETTO
NOW SCIARRETTO NOW. FORTY ONE
ON CALL CENTER THAT'S BILLS
FORTY ONE AND SOME CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
NEXT UP WE'RE MOVING ON TO- SB
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT THE CENTER
LEYVA. MARKET IN THE CZECH CARE
AFTERNOON MEMBERS EITHER A
SUMMER COOPER I WAS THINKING IN
MY SEVEN YEARS HERE THIS MIGHT
BE THE FIRST TIME I PRESENTED.
A BILL IN FRONT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE HOW COULD NOT BE
ACTED. HOW COULD THAT BE GOOD
LUCK. ARTLESS YES. I SHOULD BE
WORRIED A LITTLE BIT LIKE A
REALLY GOOD LOOK IT. AS B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PROTECTS THE
PROMISED AND PAID FOR REQUIRE
RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF CALPERS
MEMBERS THAT MAKING SURE THAT
NO HARM COMES TO RETIREE FOR
ANY COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION THAT
WAS REPORTED TO THE SYSTEM.
THIS MAJOR RESPONSE IT TO CASES
IN WHICH PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION AVERAGE QUITE
RETIRED EMPLOYEES IS
RETROACTIVELY DEEMED DISALLOWED
BY CALPERS. IN THESE INSTANCES
THE RETIRED EMPLOYEES ARE
FORCED TO PAY BACK THE TOTAL
OVERPAYMENT AMOUNT IS WILL
SUFFER PERMANENT REDUCTIONS TO
THEIR PENSIONS. MANY RETIREES
LIVE ON FIXED INCOMES AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
UNEXPECTED CUTS TO THEIR
BENEFITS AT NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN LONG AFTER THEY'VE RETIRED.
SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT GIVES
RETIREES IMPORTANT PEACE OF
MIND THAT THE RETIREMENT THAT
THEY EARNED AND PAID FOR OVER A
LIFETIME OF PUBLIC SERVICE WILL
CONSISTENTLY BE THERE
THROUGHOUT THE RETIREMENT
YEARS. SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS FOR
CALPERS EMPLOYERS TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PROTECT RETIREE
BENEFITS AND PREVENT THESE
INSTANCES FROM EVER HAPPENING
IN THE FIRST PLACE. SB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO COMPELS
EMPLOYERS TO KEEP THEIR PROMISE
PROMISE RETIREES AND HOLD THEM
HARMLESS FROM ANY REDUCTIONS TO
THE RETIREMENT AS A RESULT OF
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AS DOUG
SUBER'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
MEMBERS AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SUBER'S.
THANK YOU WITH THE CARE AND
MEMBERS. OF THE HALF OF
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. THANKS ARE LIVE
UP FOR ONGOING LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE THIS ISSUE FIRST
CAME TO THE C. P. AFTER. A
FIREFIGHTER WHO WAS. EMPLOYED
BY THE CITY OF DAVID FOR TIRED
AFTER SERVING THE PUBLIC FOR
THIRTY YEARS FIVE YEARS INTO
HER RETIREMENT- SHE WAS
NOTIFIED BY CALPERS THAT
REPORTED SPECIAL COMPENSATION
BY- THE CITY WAS DETERMINED TO
BE DISALLOWED. PLAN WHEN
CALPERS NOTIFIED SORRY WHEN
CALPERS NOTIFIED THE RETIREE-
THAT THERE WAS AN OVERPAYMENT
THE CITY. EXCUSE ME CALPERS NOT
DID NOT SEEK THE REPAYMENT FROM
THE CITY THEY REAP SOUGHT THAT
PAYMENT FROM THE RETIRED
FIREFIGHTER. IT WAS A LUMP SUM
OF FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
HER RETIREMENT GOING FORWARD.
SO WE BELIEVE THIS BILL. REALLY
WILL PROTECT THE RETIREES- THAT
ARE SIMILARLY SITUATED TO THE
FIREFIGHTER AND DAVIS LIKE MANY
RETIREES ON A FIREFIGHTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE RETIRES THEY WERE
LYING TO FIX MONTHS MONTHLY
PENSION TO MEET THEIR DAY TO
DAY NEEDS. AND MANY RETIREES
INCLUDING PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL DO NOT HAVE ACCESS OR
GET SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS SO
THIS IS REALLY THERE ONE SOURCE
OF INCOME. SO THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT THOSE RETIREES AND IN
THERE ARE CLEAR RULES AROUND-SPECIAL COMPENSATION- THE
RETIREES- CAN BARGAIN FOR AND
THOSE ARE LIKE HAZARD PAY
LONGEVITY PAY EDUCATIONAL
INCENTIVE PAY. AND WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL REALLY ENSURE
THAT WHEN THOSE THINGS ARE
BARGAINED AND PAID FOR- THEY
WILL BE MAINTAINED AS PROMISED
AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OB. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THAT'S ONLY
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
LET'S MOVE ON THE WITNESSES IN
THE HEARING ROOM- SEEING NONE.
WILL WITNESS IS ENOUGH. IN
SUPPORT. OPERATOR YOU CAN- TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZEROS SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
TO SEGREGATE. ACTUALLY WE WILL
START WITH LINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN RESPECT AROUND WITH
THEIR LEGAL ASSOCIATE
REPRESENTING THE RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL BY THE- COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE
ANOTHER ONE WITH AN OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT FOR ANYBODY ELSE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME AND WE WILL BOTTOM LINE
SEVENTY NINE. J. WORKS OVER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
RETIREES AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERVISORS
THAT THE COURT. AND THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT. FOR SB TWO SEVENTY
EIGHT AND- WE ORDER- TIMELINE
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY
YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE ON MUTE. HI
THIS IS JOE I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE PEACE OFFICERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA PORAC IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT REMOVED OPPOSITE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. SALUTE TO
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE MOVE THE PHONE LINE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME SO THE
OPERATOR CAN GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL GO TO LINE.
SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIGHLIGHTS
AFTER ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE FIFTY SIX. REMEMBERS DOING
GIVENS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. PINE FIFTY THREE
YOU ARE OPEN. FIFTY THREE
PLEASE ON MUTE. ONE LAST TRY
FIFTY THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TESTIFY. LEVINE ALONG WITH
OVERLYING FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
TERRIFYING YEP OF THE PLASTER
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHARING THEMSELVES WITH THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CARLSBAD IN BELMONT
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO FIFTY
TO SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
FIND FIFTY THREE YOUR OPEN. ONE
FIFTY THREE ARE YOU MUTED. ONE
LAST CRY FIFTY THREE PLEASE ON
MUTE. FIFTY THREE. YOUR OPEN.
OKAY ALONG WITH ONLINE SEVENTY
FIVE. WHAT. YOU ARE OPEN
SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS SEND NASH ABOUT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS ARE NOT
A DOCTOR W. EDUARDO I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
STATE BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IT'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. D. THREE
EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
THREE YOUR OPEN. THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES HI THIS IS
RYAN VISIT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN OPPOSITION. LINE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HI THIS IS CARLOS MACHADO WITH
A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. FIND
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE ON YOU. ONE
LAST TRY SIXTY FOUR WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL. WELL THE ONE WE
WERE LINE EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BALK INVOLVED
WITH SOMEBODY UP THE CITIES OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA TORRANCE
THOUSAND OAKS AND LAKE WOULD
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCCANN
UNDER WOULD ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS EXPECT
OPPOSITION. ADELINE EIGHTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANDREA BALL ON THE HALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU. WILL BRING
BACK THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
DOUBLE BILL YES. SO. I HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
RETIREMENT BENEFITS FOR THIRTY
NINE YEARS IN THE INSURANCE
BUSINESS NOW. WHEN CALPERS.
CALCULATES THE BENEFITS THE
EMPLOYEE WHOEVER THEY MAY BE
FIGURES THAT'S THE LAW THAT'S
IT THEY'RE DONE. I WOULD ACCEPT
THAT IF I WAS. THE EMPLOYEE SO.
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IS IT TO
FIGURE THIS OUT. NUMBER ONE.
THE DIFFERENT CITIES AND
JURISDICTIONS THAT. NEED TO
KNOW. WHAT THEY DID. IN THE
PAST PRESENT OR FUTURE. CALPERS
IS ONLY DOING THEIR JOB. THEIR
JOB IS TO COLLECT MONEY AND IF
THERE'S A SHORTFALL. THEY'RE
JUST DOING THEIR JOB. SO THE
POINT I'M MAKING IS I WILL.
SUPPORT THIS BILL ASSEMBLY OUT
OF JUSTICE YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS
USE THE WORD JUSTICE TODAY. BUT
THE EMPLOYEE. ONLY DOES NINE
OUT OF TEN TIMES WHAT THEY'RE
TOLD. AND IF THEY'RE GETTING
MONEY. FROM THE STATE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK THEY ASSUME IT'S A
CORRECT AMOUNT. SO WHY SHOULD
THEY BE ON THE HOOK FOR THE
DIFFERENCE IT SHOULD BE THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
ENTITIES. THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
FIGURE THIS OUT SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN MY MIND ONLY ONE
PERSON'S MIND. IS A LEVEL OF
INCOMPETENCE HERE THAT AFFECTS
PEOPLE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU THE SEATTLE THANK YOU
MR VOEPEL. I HAVE A TENDENCY TO
AGREE WITH US SOME OF THE
POINTS MR VOEPEL- I WAS MAKING-
YOUR BOTTOM LINE IS EMPLOYEES
DON'T FIGURE OUT THEIR
RETIREMENT. DíAS THAT'S A-
PRODUCT OF THE WORK OF THE CITY
AND CALPERS TOGETHER IN CALPERS
ONLY PUTS TOGETHER WITH THE
CITY HERE. I WOULD CALL THIS
THE GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
BILL. BECAUSE IF YOU GET IT
RIGHT FIRST TIME THE NOBODY HAS
TO WORRY ABOUT ANYTHING
EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES CAN PLAN
THEIR RETIREMENT ACCORDINGLY.
AND MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THEIR
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS DO WHATEVER
THEY NEED TO DO- BUT THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO GO ON. BY IF A
MISTAKE IS MADE IT IS UP TO THE
PERSONS THAT MAKE THE MISTAKE.
TO RIGHT THAT WRONG. AND HE
CAN'T DROP IN THE LAP OF
SOMEBODY WHO HAD NO PART OF
FIGURING OUT THE FORMULA FIRST
PLACE. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW IT
HAS AFFECTED SOME PEOPLE OUT
THERE-YEAH AND YOU KNOW TO THE
CITIES I UNDERSTAND THEIR
POSITION- YOU KNOW NOBODY WANTS
TO HAVE TO PAY BUT SOMEBODY
PAYS FOR MISTAKES. AND IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT THOSE
LABOR ATTORNEYS ARE FOR THEY
ARE HIRED BY CITIES IS TO MAKE
SURE YOU DO IT RIGHT THE FIRST
TIME- SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR COOLEY.
I JUST WANT TO JOIN ON. THE
COMMENTS OF BOTH MY COLLEAGUES
I THINK- EXORCISMS EXISTS TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
THAT THEY CAN- ENJOY RETIREMENT
AND SECURITY RETIREMENT WELL
THAT'S A BENEFACTION FOR THEM
WELL THAT'S A GOOD THING FOR
THEM IS ACTUALLY VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THE ECONOMY. BECAUSE THAT
MEANS EVEN A DOWNTURN. A SENIOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE CAN ACTUALLY
OPT TO RETIRE- FOR WHATEVER
REASON THE MOTIVATES THIS OPENS
UP NEW JOBS TO PEOPLE IN THE
ORGANIZATION. SO THAT IN
GENERAL PENSION SYSTEMS ARE
GOOD FOR THE WHOLE ECONOMY.
THEY ALLOW FOR THE RENEWAL OF
ORGANIZATIONS BRINGING PEOPLE
AND SO. MY POINT IS THAT
ACTUALLY THIS IS A- THERE IS A
PUBLIC BENEFITS ARE BY THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE GENERAL
HEALTH OF THE LAW. IS TO
SUPPORT THE WORKER AND TAKE THE
BURDEN OFF THEM PROVIDE THEM
WITH BENEFITS. IF WE DON'T HAVE
A FIX LIKE THIS. IT SORT OF
PUTS ON THE WORKER. THE BURDEN
OF THE MISCALCULATION AND I
AGREE- IT HELPS PEOPLE PLAN
THEIR BENEFITS AS MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES JUST STATED AND IT
ALSO. I THINK THE ONE PERSON IS
REALLY MONITORING THEIR THE
STATE OF THEIR RETIREMENT WHAT
THEY PROJECT FOR THE RETIREMENT
IS THE WORKER TRYING TO MEASURE
WHAT THEY WISH TO DO. I
APPRECIATE THEIR FOR THE FACT
THAT IN THE BILL SECTION ONE
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE EXAMPLE
FIREFIGHTER THAT THOUGHT IT WAS
ON TRACK AND IN FIVE YEARS IN
RETIREMENT. THEY TRY TO RE
COMPUTE FULL MONEY BACK. THIS
WAY ABSENCE INDIVIDUAL APPLE
KERR. AND FOR THE PERSON'S NOT
RETIRED. IF THERE WAS A
MATERIAL ERROR THAT HAD COME TO
LIGHT. THEY ACTED IN LIKE IT
THEY MIGHT CONSIDER VOTE WITH
THEIR FEET AND SEEK ANOTHER
THAT'S RIGHT SETTING IN WHICH
TO WORK. FOR RETIREMENT
INTEREST AND- SO ON EVERY LEVEL
THIS IS VERY VERY BAD FOR FOLKS
IN THE WORKFORCE. AND I AGREE
IT IS A MATTER OF FAIRNESS ND
TO GET IT RIGHT THE FIRST TIME
SO I JOIN IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL IS OUR EMOTIONAL DID YOU.
MOTION MAY. SECOND EVOLUTION A
SECOND CONSIDER THINGS WILL
BRING THIS BILL FOR THIS
IMPORTANT DETECTOR OF THE THIS-
WEIRD IT DEFINED BENEFIT. YEAH
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING
DEFINED BENEFIT YOU WORK A
CERTAIN TIME. AND YOU TOLD ME
TO MAKE THE SALARY TO COME
BACK. IT'S REALLY DISHEARTENING
AND IN SOME CASES AND WE THINK
ABOUT THIS THE AVERAGE PERS
RETIREMENT. IS THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH THAT'S
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
BEFORE TAXES THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS BEFORE TAXES.
IT'S NOT A LOT OF MONEY. IF
YOUR TEACHER IT'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. A YEAR
AND MOST OF THOSE TEACHERS ARE
WOMEN. SO TO REALLY GO BACK IN
AND TRY TO CALL THAT MONEY BACK
IS NOT RIGHT. THE ENTITIES THE
CITIES COUNTIES. THEY GOT DO A
BETTER JOB OF COMPUTING. SO
WHAT DO YOU DOUBLE CHECK AND
TRIPLE CHECK IT. IT'S ALL ON
YOU. BUT TO PUT ON THE BACK OF
THE EMPLOYEES IS WRONG- THIS
BILL THIS BILL DOESN'T ENJOY A
DO PASS- SO WE GOT A FIRST THE
SECOND. SECRETARY FOR ME OF
LOCAL POLICE. CAN I JUST SAY
ONE THING ALL OF OUR LOCAL
SENATOR THANK. I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT THE
WORKER- I THOUGHT ON A PENSION
FUND FOR TWELVE YEARS BEFORE
RUNNING FOR OFFICE. AND THE
PERSON OR THE PEOPLE WHO DID
THE CALCULATIONS WE TOLD THEM
YOU NEED TO DOUBLE TRIPLE
QUADRUPLE CHECK THOSE
CALCULATIONS. BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE MAKING LIFE DECISIONS BASED
ON WHAT WE TELL THEM AND FOR
ALL OF THE EMPLOYERS. THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION THEY HAVE
THE ABILITIES TO SUBMIT THOSE.
DEMO USE AND CBA'S TO CALPERS
AND CALPERS HAS TO GIVE THEM A
RESPONSE WITHIN NINETY DAYS AND
LET THEM KNOW THAT THERE'S ANY
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION IN
THERE. SO THERE IS A WAY TO DO
IT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
BENEFITS BUT I JUST WANNA THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR LOOKING OUT FOR
WORKING PEOPLE THANK YOU VERY-MUCH. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU.
RUSSELL PLEASE. ON SENATE BILL
TWO SEVEN EIGHT BY SENATOR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
HI VOEPEL RIGHT VOEPEL AYE
CALDERON CALDERON HI COOLEY
COOLEY I O'DONNELL RODRIGUEZ.
SAY ARE TO HI SEE ARTICLE BY.
PLEDGES FIVE VOTES ON CALL. THE
BILL HAS FIVE OLD PHONE CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR AND YOU
HAVEN'T THE NEXT BILL IS THE SB
TWO NINETY FOUR WHEELING KIND
OF KEEPING WITH A THEME OF THE
DAY. SB TWO NINETY FOUR REMOVES
THE TWELVE YEAR MAXIMUM SERVICE
CREDIT CAP THAT CAN BE EARNED
BY AN EDUCATOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA CAN
TAKE A LEAVE OF ABSENCE FROM
HER JOB TO ACT AS A STEWARD OR
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
RESPECTIVE STATE OR NATIONAL
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION. THE
JUNIOR REPRESENTATIVES MAY
SPEND SEVERAL YEARS AWAY FROM
THE OFFICE OR CLASSROOM
ADVOCATING FOR IMPROVED WORKING
CONDITIONS AND EMPLOYEE RIGHTS
WELL I SERVICE CAP IS NOT
APPLIED TO EVERY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE INCLUDING PEACE
OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS AND CITY
AND COUNTY EMPLOYEES IT DOES
APPLY TO EDUCATORS. SB TWO
NINETY FIVE TO NINETY FOUR
EXCUSE ME SIMPLY REMOVE THIS
TWELVE YEAR CAP TO ENSURE THE
EDUCATORS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
IT YOU IN HERE IN SUPPORT. IS
US UP RAMEL WITH THE CTA AND
TRISTEN BROWN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. THANK YOU. FOR FIRST
UP ON PURPOSES IS- JUST
UMBRELLA. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD TO BE BACK TRISTEN
BROWN CFT UNION ALLOCATORS
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS WE
REPRESENT JUST ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
ACROSS THE STATE WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO BE CO SPONSORING
THIS BILL THE CTA AND THANK YOU
TO SENATOR LEYVA FOR CARRYING
THIS TORCH AS SHE ALREADY
MENTIONED THE EDUCATORS IN THE
STATE ARE THE ONLY ONES THAT
FACE THIS INTERESTING QUIRK. TO
HAVE A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICE THEY CAN PROVIDE TO
THEIR UNION- I THINK THAT THERE
IS A WHILE WE HAVE A DEBATE
SOMETIMES IN THIS HOUSE ABOUT
TERM LIMITS I THINK WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
EXPERIENCE IS IN LEADERSHIP.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
TAKEN THE TIME TO RUN AND BE
DULY ELECTED TO LEADERSHIP AND
THEIR EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
AND EXPERIENCE BE GETS BETTER
ORGANIZATIONS BETTER AND MORE
EFFICACIOUS ORGANIZATIONS I CAN
REPRESENT THE INTERESTS OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE MUCH BETTER
SO WHY CURRENT LAW PUTS A CHILL
ON THAT SERVICE WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PROVIDING THAT SERVICE
AS AN ELECTED LEADER. AND THE
RETIREMENT SECURITY IS A
INTERESTING QUICK WE DON'T HAVE
AN ANSWER TO AND WE'RE HAPPY
THAT THIS BILL IS HERE TO FIX
AND REMEDY THAT SITUATION SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS IF THEY ARE
ELECTED CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
IN THESE GREAT ROLES AND BRING
THAT EXPERIENCE WITH THEM AND-
HOPEFULLY DO A BETTER JOB SO WE
THANK YOU AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT PART ME WITNESSES
SUPPORT. THE SELF BRAMBLE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SEPT BROWN BOTH SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY FOUR. LOTS BEEN SAID
SOMETHING TO KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF BUT WE DO WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STUFF. FOR THE CLEAR
AND WELL WRITTEN ANALYSIS AND
THANK SENATOR LEYVA. FOR
CARRYING OUT- THIS VERY SIMPLE
BILL TO CREATE PARITY BETWEEN
EDUCATORS AND OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. THE CHANGES
PROPOSED- SIMPLY ANSWER THE
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK FOR. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THEIR
UNION. EVERY OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE AT YOUR- THE. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT. YEAH NEVER MOVED
TO WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM. IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE DAVID CHIU PIRATE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO NINETY FOUR AND THANKFUL
TO HER LEYVA FOR AUTHORING THE
BILL. THANK YOU. REMOVE THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR. BUTTE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO AND FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR S. B.
NINETY FOUR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH WINE EIGHTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LIBBY SANTOS ON BEHALF OF S. E.
I. U. CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. AND
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO AND FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
TO AT THIS TIME FOR THE
OPERATOR IF YOUR LINE NUMBER
EXPLORE THE LINE SIXTY. FIVE
LINE NINETY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
JEREMIAH BERGERON RAP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RESEARCHER MEMBERS
CATHERINE WITH THEIR AND READ
IT SO SEATS WILL BEGIN ORANGE
TWENTY EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU THIS REMOVED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PURPOSES WE HAVE
NONE HELLO THIS IS THE HEARING
ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY. ALTHOUGH
THIS IS ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. OPERATOR
WITH THIS IS OPPOSITION. SORRY
I WAS NEW TO MISTER CHAIR- TO
SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO NINE FOUR.
AND NOBODY IS KILLING UP. THANK
YOU RUBIO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS MISTER BOTTLE I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
THIS CORRECTS A LONG STANDING
PROBLEM THAT WE HAD CORRECTED
FOR OTHER ASSOCIATIONS
PREVIOUSLY BUT NOW WE BRING
THIS ASSOCIATION INTO THE SAME
UNDER THE SAME UMBRELLA- AND
AGAIN IT'S ONE OF PRECIADO.
YOUR EFFORTS TO FIX THIS THANK
YOU CAN IRON IS THE UNION PAYS
REDUCE OTHER OFF ON TIME SALAS
LARA BUT THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BEING A FORWARD- WE WASHING IT.
AND IT WILL. THEIR MOTION.
MISTER FIRST MISSED BOTTLE
SECOND- THE SECRETARY LOCAL
POLICE. ON SENATE BILL TWO NINE
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
AYE VOEPEL. CALDERON CALDERON
HI COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
O'DONNELL. AYE O'DONNELL AYE
RODRIGUEZ SCIARRETTO HI C. R.
TôI. I VOTES ON CALL THAT BILL
HAS FIVE VOTE THE PHONE CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
NEXT UP IS S. B. ELEVEN FINNER
CORTESE. FOR I'M SORRY FOR
LEVEL EXCUSE ME AS BEFORE
ELEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE POLICE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THEY SHOULD SAY
PERCENT OF SB FOUR ELEVEN THE
WORK AFTER RETIREMENT ACT SB
FOUR ELEVEN WILL FOLLOW CALPERS
STAFF TO WORK WITH RETIRED
MEMBERS IN POOREST RESOLVE
WORKING AFTER RETIREMENT
VIOLATIONS INEFFICIENT AND
AGREEABLE MANNER. EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS A CALPERS RETIREE TO
RETURN TO WORK WITH THE CALPERS
EMPLOYER UNDER CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS AS A THANK. ALL OF
YOU KNOW- AND AS YOU ALSO KNOW
THESE RETIREES- ALSO. KNOWN AS
RETIRED IN NEWTON AND THEY'RE
LIMITED TO NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOURS OF WORK PER YEAR.
HAVE SOME RETIREES OF COURSE DO
THIS TO SUPPLEMENT THE
RETIREMENT INCOME WHILE OTHERS
FEEL IN THE CENTRAL VACANCIES
DURING AN EMERGENCY TO ENSURE-ADEQUATE STAFFING. FOR ME
TEMPORARILY STUFF MAKING
POSITIONS WHEN NEEDED.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF THESE
RETIREES ARE CURRENTLY FACING
SIGNIFICANT. AND COMPOUNDING
PENALTIES FOR UNINTENTIONALLY
GOING OVER. THEIR CURRENT
LIMITATION UNDER SIXTY HOURS.
FOR INSTANCE THEY WEREN'T AWARE
OF THIS LIMITATION REPORTER
MOVE IN A VARIETY MISINFORM THE
TERMS OF THEIR EARLY TOTALS. SB
FOUR ELEVEN WOULD SIMPLY. GRANT
THE CALPERS BOARD THE AUTHORITY
TO WAIVE OR REDUCE FINES FOR
THOSE RETIREES IN THE
VERTICALLY OVER THE NINERS
SIXTY ARGUMENT BASED ON THE
ACTUAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CONDITIONS OF THAT PARTICULAR
VIOLATION. WITHOUT HAVING TO
FORCE A RETIREE TO REINSTATE
BACK INTO THE SYSTEM. THIS WILL
PUT AN END TO WHAT IN SOME
CASES CAN AMOUNT TO AN
EGREGIOUS INCOMERS ARE RETIREES
WHO COMPOUNDING IN INCREASE
PENALTIES AND INSTEAD. ALLOW
FOR MORE SWIFT AND EFFECTIVE
RESOLUTION TO THESE
UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS. OUR
RETIREES DESERVE RESPECT OF
COURSE PEACE OF MIND AND A
SENSE OF SECURITY FOR THEIR
FUTURE. AS A CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR STATE SCHOOLS
AND PUBLIC AGENCIES ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME OF SUCH SOCIAL
ECONOMIC TURMOIL AS WE HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH. THE LIKE TO
NOTE- THAT SPONSORING THIS BILL
IS A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. INCLUDES
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM
CALPERS ALONG WITH OTHERS. WITH
US TODAY IS DAVID CHIU TARA
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AND HE'S HERE IN
PERSON THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS NOT THE ISSUE PARA
THANK. PLEASE GO AHEAD IT IS
INDEED A DEAL SORRY. AT THE
MASTERS OF IT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
KNOW MAKES IT DIFFICULT RECKON
RECOGNIZE EACH OTHER- THIS
MOMENT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LIKE ME MY NAME IS DAVID APART
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. CSEA IS THE
SPONSOR US BEFORE ELEVEN
BECAUSE THE BILL REPRESENTS A
MOVE TOWARD. FAIRNESS FOR
RETIREES FOR THE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. KNOWN AS
CALPERS. AS YOU MAY KNOW. THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE- PENSION REFORM
ACT KNOWN AS PETRA. ALLOWS
RETIREES TO WORK FOR A PUBLIC
EMPLOYER AFTER RETIREMENT. SO
LONG IS THE WAIT ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS AFTER RETIRING TO
RETURN TO WORK AND- THEY WORK
NO MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOURS PER FISCAL YEAR. IF
RETIREES EXCEED THE NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY HOUR LIMIT
UNDER CURRENT LAW. CALPERS IS
TECHNICALLY FORCED TO REINSTATE
THEM AS ACTIVE MEMBERS. A
PERSON WHO HAS DEDICATED YEARS
OF THEIR LIFE TO OUR STATE. AND
IN THE CASE OF CSEA MEMBERS TO
STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM.
IS THEN REQUIRED TO PAY BACK
ALL OF THEIR KERN RETIREE
BENEFITS THEY RECEIVED AFTER
EXCEEDING THE HOUR LIMIT BY
EVEN JUST ONE HOUR. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE RULES
THAT RETIREES MUST FOLLOW. BUT
THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
PUNISHMENT HERE OFTEN DOES NOT
FIT THE CRIME. CSEA RETIREES
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO PAY BACK SIX
FIGURES OF THEIR HARD EARNED
RETIREE BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY
WERE MISINFORMED OR MISLED BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS. PEOPLE LIVING
ON A FIXED INCOME WHO COUNT ON
THE PENSION THEY'VE EARNED HAVE
FACED MORTGAGING THEIR HOMES
BECAUSE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WHO
HAS CENTER COURT AS HE
MENTIONED OFTEN BIGGER RETIREES
TO COME BACK AND FILL CRITICAL
NEEDS THEN FAILED TO PROMPTLY
REPORT THEIR HOURS. TO CALPERS
AND NOTIFY THE RETIREE THEY'VE
CROSSED THE NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
OUR THRESHOLD. SB FOUR ELEVEN
WOULD GIVE CALPERS THE ABILITY
TO CONSIDER THESE SORTS OF
MITIGATING FACTORS. IN
DETERMINING WHETHER RETIREE
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE REINSTATED
AND HAVE TO PAY BACK THE EARNED
BENEFITS OR- IF THERE'S A MORE
REASONABLE SOLUTION. FOR
RETIREES EXCEEDED THE CAP
CONSIDERING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE. TO
GIVE CALPERS THAT LIMITED
DISCRETION TO CONSIDER THE NEW
WANTS AND FAIRNESS OF EACH
CASE. CSEA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE ON AS BEFORE ELEVEN
AND THANKS SENATOR CORTEZ HE-
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL I WILL-
JUST KNOW QUICKLY. I KNOW I
SOUND VERY FORCED A PROMISE YOU
I'M NOT ILL I APOLOGIZE TO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BUT I WAS
CHEERING ON MY PHOENIX SUNS
AGAINST THE CLIPPERS LAST
NIGHT. AND HENCE THE ODD
SOUNDING VOICE BUT- WHAT HOPE
WE DON'T HOLD THAT AGAINST ME
OR OUR ORGANIZATION- THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
BUT- I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND
THANKS AGAIN DOESN'T REQUIRE
DISEASE. THANK YOU AN
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN A
HEARING ROOM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STRESSING BROWN A CFT UNION OF
EDUCATORS CAUSED BY
PROFESSIONALS HERE IN SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANDREW WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HOPE TO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OPERATOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
OF THE PART OF SB FOUR ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
APPETITE. WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
INTO AT THE TIME. OF ONE NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
BERENBERG CALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN ONE SIXTY SEVEN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME FIND SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS PARTNERING WITH THE KERN
READING ASSOCIATION FOR
BEGINNING A RETIRED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT REMOVED WITNESSES
OPPOSITION I HAD NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WOULD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE. OF THE WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE OPPOSITION
OPERATOR. EVEN GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR ELEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
SHOWING OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE- WE DID HAVE ONE
PERSON THAT JUST YOU THAT.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WHEN I OPEN MY NUMBER NINETY
THREE. ONE NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE ABOUT WHAT. OKAY SIX
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
ROB RAP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT I APOLOGIZE I HAD
MISTER SEGMENT. OF THE HEARING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU FOR
PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY THANK YOU
WE'LL BRING BACK THE COMMUNITY
CENTER I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
COUNTY FOR THIRTY YEARS USE A
LOT OF RETIRED UNITS AND YOU
GET YOUR NICE SIXTY HOURS A
YEAR AND IT MIGHT VERY A COUPLE
DAYS HERE HOURS THERE THE
EMPLOYEE FOR THE TIME SHE THEY
REALLY DON'T KEEP TRACK OF
THEIR TIME THAT IS THE- AGENCY
THE COUNTY CITY WHATEVER IT IS.
THEY KEEP TRACK OF IT HAVE
COMPUTERS THERE THAT PROCESS
THOSETIME SHEETS SO IT TO ME
IT'S JUST A COMMONSENSE LAW
COMMONSENSE BILL THEY WILL DO A
BETTER JOB KEEPING TRACK
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHEN YOU GET
THAT CLOSE TO THAT LIMIT SO-
WANTED TO BEING IN THIS FIELD
BILL FORWARD. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHO BETTER FOR AYE MR COOLEY.
THANK SECUESTRO DE. OF NO FOR
THE COMMON- SIX WILL CALL.
SENATE FOUR ONE ONE BY SENATOR
CORTESE TO MOTIONS DO PASS AND
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE CALDERON
CALDERON HI COOLEY. COOLEY I
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I
RODRIGUEZ C. R. TôI C. R.
TÁI. EXPERTS ON CALL THAT
BILL HAS SIX MOTORCYCLE THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU GIVEN THE
SECURE IN SOME OF THE
RESTRICTIONS. THEY'RE MOVING
UNDER- SB FOUR TWENTY TWO
CENTER PAN. GOOD AFTERNOON DR
GRANT. GOOD AFTERNOON. ALL
RIGHT. THANKS. TO OKAY YOU KNOW
WHAT NOT USED TO BEING SO CLOSE
HERE ALL RIGHT SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- CHAIR HOW MEMBERS
TODAY PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY
TWO A BILL THAT WILL SAVE THE
STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PERSONNEL COSTS IMPROVE PATIENT
OUTCOMES BY EXTENDING WORKFORCE
FLEXIBILITY TO CIVIL SERVICE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. SB FOUR
TWENTY TO SELL THIS IS A
PROFESSIONAL MEDICAL REGISTRY
COMPOSED OF STATE EMPLOYEES
THAT SERVE. THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HAD THE
DEPARTMENT CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION. THE BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS CURRENT LABOR LAWS
THAT LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF HOURS
THE CIVIL SERVICE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL CAN PERFORM BEFORE
THE STATE IS REQUIRED TO USE
MORE COSTLY. THIRD PARTY
CONTRACTORS TRADITIONAL
SERVICES. UNDER THE CURRENT
MODEL THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS
CHARGE THE STATE'S
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FOR SERVICES
COMPARED THESE TO THE USE OF
EXISTING STATE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. IT'S REGISTRY
HAS BEEN PROVEN SUCCESSFUL IN
THE COUNTY LOS ANGELES. THE
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS LAUNCHED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN RESULTING IN
SAVINGS OF OVER ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THIS BILL
ENSURES FURTHER SAVINGS BY
LIMITING ADDITIONAL HOURS SIR
BY PARTICIPANTS. THE MAXIMUM
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A WEEK.
PARTICIPATION IN THE REGISTRY
WILL ALSO CONSTITUTE TEMPORARY
WORK AND REGISTRY PARTICIPANTS
WILL FOREGO ANY EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS ON TRADITIONAL HOURS.
FURTHERMORE ADDITIONAL HOURS
NOT BE COUNTED TOWARD THE
CALCULATION OF THE EMPLOYEES
PENSION. SB FOUR TWENTY TWO IS
A SENSIBLE COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO SAVING THE STATE
MONEY MATURING TO THE STATE
MAINTAINS A COTTON WOULD CARE
FOR ITS PATIENTS. PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL SUNSET ON JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN I HAVE-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DR KIM AND
DR STUART FUSSY. PRESIDENT THE
UNION AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS TO SPEAK MORE ON THIS
ISSUE AND ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. I FELT THE ASPEN
HIGH BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WILL MOVE TO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT FIRST UP IS DOCTOR
BUSSY- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DR STUART BUCKING UP
PRESIDENT OF THE UNION. OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS APSIDAL TWO OH SIX. I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THAT
SPEECH FOR TWENTY TO. ADD
DOCTOR PAN SAID THE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL WILL GO A LONG WAY
TOWARDS PRODUCING BETTER
CONTINUITY OF CARE. FOR
CALIFORNIA'S INMATES AND
HOSPITALIZED MENTALLY ILL. AND
IT WILL SAVE TAXPAYERS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
CONTRACTING OUT OF STATE
EMPLOYEE HEALTH CARE POSITIONS.
HAS REMAINED A PROBLEM FOR
DECADES IN THE STATE IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. I TESTIFIED I
RECOMMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE PRETEND
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS. TO
MITIGATE THIS PROBLEM. AND- THE
REGISTRY WAS ONE OF THEM. HI
MORE HOPEFUL. THE STATE AND PD
HAVE COLLABORATED RECENTLY IN A
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION STUDY
OVER THE PAST. NINE MONTHS. IN
THIS JOINT REPORT STATISTICS
HAVE SHOWN A FEDERALLY
INCREASING AMOUNT OF MONEY.
BEING SPENT ON PRIVATE HEALTH
CARE CONTRACTORS TO BACK FILL
THE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POSITION VACANCIES IN CDCR AND
D. S. H. THE STATE HOSPITALS.
ONE CONTRACTOR IT MADE EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AT ONE.
AND ONE MONTH. THE STATE PAID
CONTRACTORS ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
BARGAINING SIXTEEN BARKING AT
SIXTEEN WORK. AND MILLIONS MORE
ONE CONTRACTING OUT BARGAINING
NINETEEN PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL
WORKERS PHARMACISTS. BUT
COLEMAN COURT SPECIAL MASTERS
REPORTED TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
REQUIRE GREAT RECOMMENDED
BETTER SALARY OPPORTUNITIES. TO
RETAIN OUR STATE CIVIL SERVICE
POSITIONS. THANK YOU WAITING
AGO SHARED PREVIOUSLY
ADDITIONAL APPOINTMENT LANGUAGE
IN A TEMPLE YOU WITH THE STATE
WHICH WERE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE
EXTRA MANPOWER BY THE STATE
EMPLOYEES. AT A BASE SALARY
WAIT WHICH WAS ONE HALF OF A
PRIVATE CONTRACT BUT THAT'S FAR.
WHICH SO THEREFORE SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO COMES ALONG WITH A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE OF AN
EMPLOYEE REGISTRY. WOULD ENSURE
THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM TO SUPPLY MORE
RELIABLE HEALTHCARE AT
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER COST STATE
EMPLOYEES IN CONTRAST TO
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS ALREADY
KNOW THEIR PATIENTS. AND THE
INSTITUTIONS THEY WORK AND THEY
WOULD PROVIDE BETTER CONTINUITY
AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND 35% OF
THEIR BASE SALARY DR PAN SAID
THERE'S NO BENEFITS. IT'S JUST
A PREMIUM SORRY AND THAT'S
BETTER THAN THE CONTRACTORS
2100% RATE SO YOU SEE IT'S AN
OBVIOUS COST SAVINGS THE
PROPOSED REGISTRY WILL BE
MODELED AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL L.
A. COUNTY REGISTRY. OF THOSE
REGISTRY PROFESSIONALS AND
THEIR PATIENTS ARE HAPPY AT THE
COUNTY OF L. A. HAS SAVED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO IS A- OR TWENTY TWO
ZERO. CARACOL THE SAME RESULTS
FOR THE STATE. I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT UP IN SOCCER CAMP. MY NAME
IS DR KIM THANK YOU CHAIR AND
SENATE COMMITTEE. ON A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ITS PEOPLE TWENTY
TO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE-
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WHEN-
FORMING A STATE REGISTRY WILL
HELP STRENGTHEN THE BARGAINING
UNIT SIXTEEN AND NINETEEN AND
STRONGER UNION ME STRONGER
CALIFORNIA STRONG WORKFORCE
THEY WERE PORTED BETTER FOR
CALIFORNIA. IT ALSO DID
REGISTRY OR WOULD LIKE TALK
ABOUT THE A DR PAMELA THANK YOU
GOT TO KEEP OUR COSTS AS LOW
LOWER THAN HAVING CONTRACTORS
SOME CONTRACT MAKING THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS PER HOUR
AS OPPOSED TO REGULAR EMPLOYEES
THAT MAKING ONE FIFTY AN HOUR.
SO WHAT THEY DOING THE THING
MARC THAT WE'RE GOING AND THAT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE GETTING PAID
LIKE DOUBLE TIME MORE AND
THERE'S NO NONSENSE BECAUSE
WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT WORK IN A
MORE OF A COST EFFECTIVE MATTER
AND WE CAN WE ARE VESTED IN THE
STATE. THAT STATE EMPLOYEES
WERE VESTED IN IN OUR
INSTITUTION WE KNOW THE
PATIENTS THERE WE'RE GONNA- OF
SUPPORT WE GOT TO PROVIDE A
BETTER QUALITY OF CARE AND
BETTER CARE OVAL AT A CHEAPER
MATTER SO IT MAKES COMPLETE
SENSE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
PUSH THIS THROUGH. AND IT'S
GOING TO BE BETTER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE STATE
HOSPITAL NCDC ARE TRAPPED BEING
EMPLOYEES WORKING AND WORKING
HARD TO TAKE CARE OF A PATIENT
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I HOPE THAT YOU GOT SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT REMOVED. WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE MOVE
THE WITNESSES ON THE LINE.
OPERATOR WHEN IS THE- LATE AND
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK THE PORT
OF S. FOUR TWO TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. AT
THE TIME PER. LINE SEVENTY FOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO AGAIN
CHAIRED MEMBERS COULD STOP BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
ISSUE THAT CURRENTLY WITH
READER ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR GEORGE OSBORNE
REPRESENTING YOU ATD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF- SB FOUR TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER WHY
APOLOGIZE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR TWO TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR.
NEXT REMOVED OF WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. SALUTE TO PREP WHEN
THIS IS NOT POSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE. WILL
BACK THE PHONE LINE WHEN THIS
IS OPPOSITION OPERATOR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
TWO TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR TWO TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO ONE- SHOWN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE IN WHICH WILL HELP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO. I
LIKE THIS BILL I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BUT I WOULD LIKE TO TELL
YOU WHY BECAUSE THIS IS IN
COOL SO I SPENT THIRTY NINE
YEARS IN THE INSURANCE BUSINESS
AND IT TOOK ME THOSE MANY YEARS
TO GET UP MY LAST TWELVE YEARS
TO BE ABLE TO DESIGN HEALTH
CARE PLANS. SO I'M A DESIGNER
OF HEALTH CARE PLANS AN
INDUSTRY EXPERT AT LEAST I
THINK SO. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE DOCTORS AND
PSYCHIATRISTS AND ALL IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD SO EMERGENCY
ROOM DOCTORS GENERALLY WORKED
THERE SIXTY HOURS A WEEK AS
REGULAR DOCTORS THE WORK
ANOTHER EIGHTEEN OR TWENTY
HOURS A WEEK IN THE EMERGENCY
ROOM BECAUSE OF NAY THEY CAN
MAKE OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TO THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
THEIR PAY. WITH THE EBB AND
FLOW OF EMERGENCY ROOM
SERVICES. AND MANY OF THOSE
DOCTORS ENGAGE IN BEING HIGH
LEVEL GUNSHOT WOUND
SPECIALISTS. SO IF WE'RE ONLY
GOING A 135% HERE. CROSS THE
BORDER HOLD MAN I'M THERE TRUST
ME CENTERED AROUND THERE ON THE
OTHER THING IS WE HAVE A MAJOR
SHORTAGE OF DOCTORS BECAUSE
MANY OF AMER BABY BOOMERS LIKE
ME THEY'RE PULLING UP THE PLUG
AND REMOVING THE IDAHO. SO IF I
WAS WRITING THIS BILL I WOULD
BE GONE FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PERCENT. JUST SO YOU KNOW.
ANYWAY GREAT BILL I SUPPORTED.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SIR THE
MOTION. WELL YEAH. THANK YOU.
ZERO SIR I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THIS A LITTLE
BETTER- CURRENTLY THE CONTRACT
OUT IN A COST THREE TIMES AS
MUCH AS IF THEY HAD JUST HIRED
BACK ONE OF THEIR OWN PEOPLE.
WHY ON EARTH WOULD ANYBODY DO
THAT. BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU'RE
IN CHARGE OF A BUDGET. I FEEL
LIKE I'M MISSING PART OF THE
PICTURE IF YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF
THE BUDGET. AND YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT. NOT SPEND
THIS AND SPEND ONLY THIS. THEN
YOU WOULD DO THAT. SO THERE'S
GOTTA BE A REASON THAT THEY'RE
DOING THAT. IT IS IT BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH- PHYSICIANS
TO HIRE BACK. BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE THE ONLY REASON IF
THERE'S NOBODY AVAILABLE THEN
THEY THEY HAVE TO DO THAT AND
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRECLUDE
THEM FROM CONTRACTING OUT IF
THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH POSITION
TO DO IT CORRECTLY. EXACTLY SO.
I CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
ADMINISTRATION- SO THAT
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE THE ONES WHAT
WE'RE- FOR SOME REASON- THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN. IS INTERESTED IN
CREATING A REGISTRY WHICH THEN
WOULD CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY LOOK YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE
YOUR OWN DOCTORS WHO ARE
WILLING TO. DO SOME EXTRA TIME
RIGHT AND ACTUALLY HAD A LOWER
RATE THAN YOU WOULD PROBABLY
HAVE TO SAY THAT YOU ARE
SPENDING NOT JUST HAVE TO SPEND
THAT YOU ARE CURRENTLY
SPENDING. FOR CONTRACTING
CONTRACTED OUT DOCTORS SO TO
US- TO THE SPONSOR TONIGHT THIS
JUST MAKES A LOT OF SENSE IT
SAVES MONEY. THE DOCTORS
THEMSELVES ACTUALLY NOTICES
CELANESE IT'S NOT LIKE YOU JUST
BRING IN A HIRED GUN HIS LIKE-
WHERE'S THE STUFF AND WHERE HOW
TO PLAY FILED YOU KNOW IT'S
EVERYWHERE TO THINGS. AND SO
NOW I'VE THANK YOU FOR THAT
OKAY WELL THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS. SO WE'VE GOT
A MOTION AND SECOND OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASSED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS- WE
ROLL CALL PLEASE SECRETARY.
UNSUITABLE FOR TWO TWO BY
SENATOR PAN MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER HI VOEPEL. HI
VOEPEL I CALDERON CALDERON I'D
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I RODRIGUEZ
SCIARRETTO NOT VOTING C. R. TO
NOT VOTING. THIS BRINGS US TO
OUR LAST AUTUMN SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT CENTER PAN AND SERGEANTS
CAN YOU CALL THE F. MEMBERS
LAUREL LAST AUTUMN PLEASE. DR
BEN THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
COOPER AND MEMBERS AND CREATE
THE PREVIOUS DISCUSSION SO SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD ALLOW
EMPLOYEES ANOTHER COST SAVING
BILL ACTUALLY AND FROM MY
DISTRICT IT'S ALLOWS. EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS AT SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT RIGHT
HERE- TO MOVE UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGES. TO THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
CURRENTLY THE DISTRICT AND
SIMPLY ORGANIZATIONS MUST GO
THROUGH THE OVER BURDENED AND
UNDER RESOURCE SUPERIOR COURT
SYSTEM FOR CONFLICT RESOLUTION.
THIS EXISTING PROCESS IS TIME
CONSUMING MORE EXPENSIVE AND
ACTUALLY MAY PLACE AN UNFAIR
PRACTICE CHARGE WITH THE JUDGE
WHO HAS LITTLE EXPERIENCE WITH.
A PUBLIC EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS MEETING AGAIN EVEN
MORE TIME WHEN THAT HAPPENS. IN
COMPARISON THE PROCONSUL
RESOLUTION PROCESS IS
STREAMLINED LESS EXPENSIVE FOR
THE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS AND
TAXPAYERS AND SPECIFIC THE
CONFLICT RESOLUTION WITHIN
PUBLIC SECTORS I SHOULD POINT
OUT. THAT THIS IS SUPPORTED BY
BOTH THE EMPLOYER SECOND
REGIONAL TRANSIT AND THAT THE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION SO ALL
THE PARTIES WANT THIS BUT THAT
EXPECT WE ASK WHEN I BUT TO
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY WILL OF THE-
NEXT REMOVE A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE'VE GOT TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES- FIRST OF HIS DAVID
PHILLIPS. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON FOR IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS THAT
DAVID PHILLIPS I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF APPS NEW LOCAL ONE
FORTY SIX. I'M ALSO WE- TWENTY
YEAR EMPLOYEE- SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT. OF THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM OF EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS. FALLS UNDER
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE NOT
THE MYERS MILIUS BROWN THAT.
AND- WHICH PROVIDES
JURISDICTIONS FOR MOST OF OUR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION.
THIS CURRENT SO THAT THERE IS
AN ALLEGATION OF YOUR P.
VIOLATIONS. WERE REQUIRED TO
FILE A WRITTEN SUPERIOR COURT.
THE WAY THE PROCESS IT CAN TAKE
MONTHS TO YEARS TO BE GOOD
JUDGMENT YEAH THIS COULD BE
FROM A JUDGE. THAT MAY NOT HAVE
ANY EXPERIENCE THE LABOR LAW.
THIS IS ALSO A PART OF THE
PROCESS THE TAXPAYERS ARE THE
ONES THAT END UP HAVING TO PICK
UP THE TAB FOR THESE. BOB THIS
BILL CHANGES THAT BY PLACING
SAKHAR T. UP WORKERS UNDER
PREPARE STATION. COST EFFECTIVE
THAT AT THE TIME WE WAITED
SOLVE THEM FULLY EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. IT ALSO ENSURES THAT
BOTH EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE BEGINNING
FACE. IT LIMITS INTERFERENCE
WITH THE POLIO ORGANIZATIONAL
RIGHT. AT THE SAME TIME BUT
ALSO PROTECT THE INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEES FROM BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. FOR THE
LACK OF FAIR REPRESENTATION BY
THE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THEY BELONG TO YOU- BUT AGAIN-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME NO I
HOPE WE GET A YES VOTE ON THIS
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT ARMOR WITH THIS IN SUPPORT
IS TEN CRIMMINS. BUT MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF. WHAT
THE- PRIOR OFTEN BOTH BY THE
SENATOR AND THAT. TESTIMONY OF
THE PILOTS HAVE BECOME AN
EXPEDITE MY TESTIMONY HERE AND-
MENTIONED THAT THESE ARE. YOU
OKAY ARE COSTING US ROUGHLY
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
APIECE. I NEED SOME SENATE
MANAGERS PAYING ROUGHLY THE
SAME- THIS WOULD PROTECT ATTACK
THAT PROCESS OVER PER MAKE IT
QUICKER MORE PREDICTABLE-
BETTER FOR LABOR RELATIONS
BETTER FOR MANAGEMENT. WHAT
ABOUT PREDICT PREDICTABILITY
AND THE LESS COSTS- AND I DON'T
ALSO MENTIONED THIS. IS ALSO A
CO SPONSORED BY OUR- GOOD
FRIEND THAT I UP YOUR NATURAL
LOOKED CENTER. LONG WITH US AND
ME AND I WOULD ALSO THANK THE
STAFF ON THE NECK- COMMITTEE
NOW JUST- PLEASE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
WITNESSES AND HEARING ROOM AND.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MADIGAN BEHALF OF LOCAL TWELVE
FORTY FIVE THE IBEW IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WELL NUMBER ONE THIS
IS ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q.
ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KAREN LIVING ON EHALF OF
AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BOB MAHER WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES-
WE ARE ONE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
DISPELLED STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND
A REMINDER LADIES GENTLEMEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON HERE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINETY.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU ORNAMENT AWARENESS IS
IN OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO MOVED
WITNESSES IN A HEARING ROOM. IN
OPPOSITION- SAYING NONE OF THE
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE NINE EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE SHOWING OPPOSITION PRESS
THE FIVE NINETY. OKAY I'LL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE
WILL FIRST AND SECOND RIGHT.
DOCUMENTED CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN IVAN THANK YOU THANK
YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE.
UNSUITABLE FIVE NINE EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. COOPER
HI COOPER HI VOEPEL NOT. VOEPEL
NOT VOTING CALDERON. CALDERON
HI COOLEY. COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL
AYE DONAL AYE RODRIGUEZ C. R.
TO SEE OUR TO OUR HIGH. FIVE
VOTES ON THE CALL OKAY THAT WAS
FIVE VOTES IN SOME CALL CENTER
OKAY THANKS FOR THAT YOU SHOULD.
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN AND DO
BATTLE. BELIEVE YEAH. MISCODED.
YOU START WILL START AT ARMS
SURE. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
SENATE BILL SIX THREE FOUR
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT MRS DO
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WITH A RECOMMENDATION TO
CONSENT CALENDAR. VOEPEL VOEPEL
I SIX ON CALL. THE BILL SIX
BOTH IS ON CALL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR NELSON MOTIONS
TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY VOEPEL
HI VOEPEL HI SIX ZERO ONE CALL
THAT BILL HAS SIX VOTERS ON
CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATE BILL TWO ZERO SIX BY
CENTER MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY VOEPEL.
HI VOEPEL HI SIX ZERO ONE CALL
LEVEL HAS SIX VOTES AND
FIFTIES. THE BILL SIX MODES IS
ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR
SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN ZERO BY
SENATOR DRAWS SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. VOEPEL
WROTE VOEPEL NO. FORTY TWO ON
CALL THAT BILLS FORTY TWO IT'S
ON CALL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN EIGHT BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTIONS TO
PASS A BEAVER BE RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SEVEN
ZERO FILLS OUT THAT BILL PASSES
SEVEN ZERO IT'S OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATE BILL TWO NINE
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA MOTIONS
TO PASS AND BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
VOEPEL NOBLE VOEPEL NOT VOTING
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI. SIX
ZERO PASSES THAT BILL PASSES
SIX ZERO WITHOUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SAID A BILL FOR
ONE ONE BY SENATOR CORTESE TO
MOTIONS TO PASS TO BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL PASSED THE SEVEN ZERO
WITHOUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SENATE BILL FOUR TWO TWO BY
SENATOR PAN EMOTIONS DO PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I SIXTH
ZERO FILLS OUT THAT BILL PASSES
SIX ZERO IT'S OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SENATE BILL FIVE
NINE EIGHT MOTIONS BY SENATOR
PAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I. SIX ZERO BILLS OUT THAT BILL
PASSED THE SIX ZERO IT'S OUT.
WE'LL START AT THE TOP AGAIN
FORCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
SENATE BILL SIX THREE FOUR
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT MOTIONS TO PASS TO
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ HI SEVEN
ZERO BILL PASSED WITH A BILL
PASSED THE SEVEN ZERO IT'S OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE
BILL SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR
NELSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I SEVEN
ZERO THE BILL PASSES SEVEN ZERO
WITHOUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
SENATE BILL TWO ZERO SIX BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ HI SEVEN
ZERO. THE BILL PASSES SEVEN
ZERO WITHOUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOR SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN ZERO
BY SENATOR DRAWS SO MOTIONS TO
PASS AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I FIVE TO
TWO. THAT BILLS WITHOUT
FIGHTING TO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SENATE BILL TWO SEVEN
EIGHT BY SENATOR LEYVA THE
MOTIONS DO PASS AND BE REFERRED
TO SORRY SKIP THAT ONE EXCUSE
ME TO ON PASSED ALREADY. MR THE
COMPLETE THE ROLL CALL. THAT
BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
HEARING THIS HEARINGS INCLUDED.